[Musique]
française français mes chers
compatriotes la rentrée de TPMP c'est le
4 septembre vous trouverez évidemment
Raymond l'abominable homme de Rungis
Kelly Vedovelli Delphine vespiser
Guillaume Janton Géraldine maillet la
deneuse de leçon Valou valeur
et j'ai le Verdez malheureusement la
rentrée est-elle vraiment décalée si tu
viens de te réveiller c'est là nous aime
pas manquer de la semaine j'ai pas vous
faire attendre plus que ça la réponse
est oui en effet au vu du configurique
actuel entre la Chine et la Russie et
des fortes tensions Emmanuel Macron
s'est vu dans l'obligation de réintégrer
le service militaire via le cursus
scolaire toutes ces informations étaient
rendues possibles grâce au site actu
dujour.fr qui a rendu public un document
intercepté entre Emmanuel Macron et les
préfets parlant de tout ce que je vous
ai dit
il y aura aussi Yann Moix Eric nolo les
polémistes quand on part à des débats
houleux avec certains invités dans le
but de leur défoncer leur conchetta
alors est-ce qu'on va décaler la rentrée
scolaire au 18 septembre et ben non
évidemment que non par contre si vous
êtes au collège vous aurez une heure de
français ou de maths en soutien par
semaine de plus les centaines de
collèges vont expérimenter les deux
heures de sport de plus par semaine vive
la France vive la république et vive la
darka